all right people this is the big bananas
bonkers Ruben Report end-of-the-year
clip show recapping some of my favorite
moments of 2018 before we hit the clips
though I want to take a quick moment to
thank all of you guys who listen watch
share and support the show you guys are
the engine that have kept us totally
independent for over two years now and
trust me were just getting started
2018 was by far our biggest year yet as
the intellectual dark web went
mainstream I toured over 80 cities all
over the world with Jordan Peterson I
also returned to stand up comedy check
the link down below for upcoming dates
and we continued to have the
conversations that I believe can restore
some sanity to the universe I've
actually never felt better about the
direction we're headed and with your
help we'll continue to grow so here's my
one sentence sell job help us remain
totally independent and fan funded by
going to Dave Rubin dot-com / donate
alright that's it now more importantly
thank you and enjoy some of my favorite
moments with some of my favorite people
from 2018 you were on with Kathy Newman
on it's Canada channel for know it was
UK channel 4 and there's I mean everyone
that's watching this has probably seen
this already if you haven't you should
go watch it but but in effect basically
she tried to make an argument that you
have heard a gajillion times before but
why does your right to free speech
supersede a trans person's right to feel
okay with themselves or saying even the
way she phrased the question was a
little confused and conflated but I
think what the reaction to it what you
know your your answer was great but it
was the reaction the regular people
watching at home that were going this is
nonsense
this is just object no well the only
thing that's really made it viral is the
fact that she recognized in the moments
when she was saying was nothing good
where you could see the light go on
briefly and she just went wait what did
I just say yeah and there was no escape
it was pretty was pretty grand yeah yeah
well the funny thing about her argument
is that it's print was predicated on the
idea that somehow people have a right to
be comfortable it's like that's just not
a right you have in life of all the
things you can say that you don't have a
right to in life in comfort
his number-one is what you made that
point yeah who can offend me right now
so the thing is is if you if your right
to be comfortable Trump's my right to
talk then I don't get to talk ever
because I'm going to say things if I'm
actually talking I'm going to say things
if they're if they're profound things if
they're contentious things or truthful
things I'm going to say things that if
they don't disturb you are gonna disturb
you and if they don't disturb you
there's someone that's gonna be
disturbed about them so what's the
answer to that everyone can be
comfortable in the silence but that
doesn't also doesn't work because then
we can't exchange ideas we're not
comfortable in the silence were isolated
and and in the silence so it's a
completely incoherent perspective I will
say the last time I was on your program
the only time I was on before I remember
you asking me what I thought of the left
and I quipped what left I haven't seen
him and who knows how long yeah that
turns out not to have been right they
exist I mean yes I hadn't seen them but
one of the funny things about my
trajectory is that having been you know
the experience was very much like being
ejected from the left yeah and I gotta
ejected from the left and a lot of
people on the right embraced me which
was weird and then even weirder was the
discovery of all the other people who
had been ejected from the left and so
the point is this is sort of a cryptic
left you're talking to the right guy
exactly well and so so the point is the
discovery that there are a lot of people
who you might if you just looked them up
online you would come to the wrong
conclusion about where their sympathies
lay that that's interesting and I think
the conversation between those of us who
have been you know catapulted out and
those of us who have landed on the right
is going to involve the recognition that
in fact we are all suffering from a kind
of political PTSD uh-huh and that in
fact many people who are on the right
are there because they've been
traumatized by really low quality
dangerous leftist thinking but that the
that does not make their right of center
position natural I'm not saying there
are no natural positions over there but
many people who are there are there
because they have run from things that
they have heard on the left and once we
give up on the idea that anybody on the
map today has the answer with respect to
the policies that we are supposed to
embrace once we say actually everybody's
policies are
failure if we were to enact the
libertarian program it would fail for
game theoretic reasons if we were to
enact the socialist program it would
fail for game theoretic reason same
thing right so the point is okay fresh
sheet of paper with respect to policy
now there's a lot for us to talk about
starting from values and there are a lot
of people who if you ask them to list
their values apart from policy would
fall out on the Left so Wow is it an
interesting moment that that
conversation may be about to get started
to be in a position to actually
influence it I must say is a pretty
excited one of the things that I found
out that was sort of amazing about your
history you briefly mentioned it right
before we started you were a Marxist at
one time in your life most people will
find this hard to believe but it is true
but it's not that unusual most of the
leading conservative thinkers of our
time did not start off as conservator
you got a couple like Bill Buckley and
George Will but I mean Milton Friedman
was it was it was a liberal and a
Keynesian a Hayek was a socialist Ronald
Reagan was so far left at one point the
FBI was following him you know so so
there's a huge movement from the left to
the right as people get older yeah I'm
I'm well aware as I mentioned to you
earlier as a former progressive I
understand that that movement in the
modern sense
do you remember sort of what you were
thinking what appeal to you at that time
about Marxism yes I mean there was no
alternative being discussed my first job
was as a Western Union messenger and I
would come home on some nights I would
take the Fifth Avenue bus which cost all
of 15 cents in those days but I figured
I'd splurge now and then and I would
drive it would Galway up Fifth Avenue
pass all these Lord and Taylor and all
these fancy places and then across 57th
Street pass Carnegie Hall and down
Riverside Drive now it's sort of the
Gold Coast area and then yes I came
across this long viaduct and it turned
into one hundred and thirty fifth street
suddenly there were the tenements
and I wondered why is this I mean it's
so so it's so different and then nothing
in the schools or most of the books seem
to deal with that and walks dealt with
that so it's it's it's like winning in
an election when there's only one person
running so then what was your wake up to
what was wrong with that line of
thinking facts I'm not one of those who
thinks things are worse now than they've
ever been and this is a country where we
fought over big issues for a long time
Revolutionary War of course and then of
course we had the war of 1812 we had the
Civil War World War One World War two
Vietnam Korean War we 9/11 people hated
Ronald Reagan they thought he was a war
monger George Bush was a bush life
people died there's tension in this
country there always has been for a very
long period of time we get along better
now than ever before we've been I don't
think you can understate the fact that
we elected a real lack of a black
president in the 50s the polls show that
the percentage of white Americans who
will be willing to vote for a black
person no matter how well a qualified
was in the single digits and now I think
only three or four percent of
Republicans and Democrats say that under
no circumstances would they vote for a
black person for president in fact
there's greater prejudice against the
Mormon and it gets boring for a woman
than it is voting for a black person now
so America is a very different place
than it used to be and and for the left
to act like it's not insults the men and
women who worked hard to get us to where
we are right now it's actually true to
say that Obama was basically you know as
honest as a politician it can be and
still be a politician I'm I think I'm
sure he lied about things right yeah but
there's there's no story on Obama being
just this depraved person behind closed
doors who get who's a con artist who
gets away with everything that he can
get away with
who's trailing a long list of cat you
know business and interpersonal
casualties who will tell you if you put
them on camera or you can't get them
privately these the worst person they've
ever met
right that's who's president now right
it's just it's a completely different
personality
and I think that I think so whatever
happens let's say good that let's say
we're living in a universe where having
a uniquely narcissistic selfish shallow
personality in this position of power
works out well let's just say that
middle of so let's just take your
wreckingball theory he's kind of swung
through here
yeah he's disrupted everything you know
I do view him as I said before as a kind
of evil Chauncey Gardiner character I
don't view him as this sort of mastery I
think Scott Adams is completely out to
lunch on I don't think he's this genius
manipulator I mean he's got he's got
some talents obviously yeah but I think
you think it's much less calculating
much less calculus I don't think him
contradicting himself two sentences
later right when he says you know this
is an amazing letter you'd all like to
read this letter and that he says two
sentences later I haven't read the
letter yeah
that's not calculated he's just not
doesn't have the cog he can't take the
cognitive overhead to even figure out
what you know what was logically implied
by the last thing he said right so he's
not the truth is he's not he lies all
the time but worse than lying and this
is the great distinction that the
philosopher Harry Frankfurt made in his
book on [ __ ] worse than lying is
that he's bullshitting all the time and
the difference between line and
bullshitting is that if I'm gonna lie to
you I'm paying attention to what I know
react well I know it what is true I know
you know what is true and I'm trying to
insert a lie into the space provided in
a way that you won't notice right like
I'm having to keep track of reality in
order to lie to you successfully I
understand your logical expectations I
understand that if I tell you that you
know I was an hour late here because the
traffic was so bad I can't say in the
next sentence oh I left an hour late
from my house right so like so so the
bullshitter isn't doing any of that the
bullshitter is just talking right and
therefore has renounced the reality
testing he has to do to lie successfully
and he's just he has burden
not on him to make any sense at all in
the end and that for to an amazing
degree not entirely I think he does
actually lie strategically sometimes but
to an amazing degree and this is what I
think it's so harmful about his
presidency whatever happens with North
Korea or anything else that we might you
know care about to an amazing degree he
has revealed that half of our society
will accept somebody who is just
bullshitting all the time about things
great and small and it doesn't matter
how important or how inconsequential
pornstars you know what you know what
just happened with the g7 you know what
was said behind closed doors what he's
going to say to to a some maniac with
with nukes
there's just say eight we've completely
forsaken any expectation of a
reality-based conversation and many
people seem to revel in it many people
seem to think this is just this is just
good fun it's like this is the you know
the ends it's a bit of the wrecking ball
theory yeah gone to some nihilistic
extreme where it's just let's just you
know let's just burn it all out having
gone through the looking-glass having
gone through the direct you know to
borrow a phrase from the far left but
the lived experience of actually being
at the center of a mob at the center of
riots and then watching as the world the
mainstream media and others tried to do
a public relations spin on it and tell a
totally different story to live that and
to watch the institution that you loved
to become totally disloyal to you and to
watch many people whom you respected
hide you can't don't see that it's
valuable and the fact that we're sitting
here talking together and that many of
us in you know the intellectual dark web
and in this in this bigger group are are
speaking and saying actually the culture
of fear that is society-wide
is real and so I'll say the the first
time I met my students after the
November 2016 election after Trump was
elected evergreen is a very left place
Olympia is a very left
pretty much everyone on campus had that
glazed eyes slack-jawed look that people
in most progressive enclaves will be
familiar with from that time from those
few days right
myself included even though I was no
Hillary fan but I didn't see that
outcome coming and I certainly didn't
vote for Trump I am we got to class and
my co faculty whom I admire greatly just
preceded with her lecture on horse
evolution and I'm looking around the
classroom going no one here cares about
horse er so she ended up it early and we
had lab a couple hours later and before
she let them go I said hold on if anyone
wants to stay this is no longer class
but if anyone wants to stay I would be
happy to lead a conversation about what
just happened yeah what just happened to
our country and about 40 of our 50
students stayed well skipped their lunch
hour and we went right to anatomy lab
that afternoon from from this
conversation and what I said to them was
do not for a minute believe that racists
and sexist elected Trump think about how
many times you have had to censor
yourself on this campus when you had an
opinion that was even slightly different
from the accepted dogma and that
conversation not only brought life to
the room but afterwards I had several
students come up to me some of them in
tears telling me stories about one of
them had lost a job on campus for
speaking an opinion that was not
accepted one of them had an another
story of another friend who lost a job
others talked about their self
censorship and that and all of these
people again were for left not that it
should matter but these weren't even
people who were conservatives or who
held conservative views so that that is
the larger culture of fear that is
hardly restricted to Evergreen but is
society-wide that we are that we are
speaking about and that people are
responding to because in you know at
Google at Starbucks and in cubicles in
campuses but far beyond campuses across
the country and across the weird country
is at least this is a problem Shapiro
will you bake Ruben a wedding cake
okay so I mean my answer is I'm married
already but an adverse my anniversary
last week an anniversary cake would have
been a right so I so the answer is no
and the reason I won't is because as a
religious Jew I got I do not participate
in activities that I believe are sinful
but again we live in a free country and
Dave knows this he doesn have to care
what I think about sin and as long as
I'm not bothering Dave I don't see why
it's a problem yeah so it's well I will
I did this Dave have a husband yeah I
mean like okay and are we friends yeah
and are we gonna go out to dinner
sometime in the near future
yeah but but there's a difference
between me just being friends with Dave
and me actively participating in an
event that I feel is religiously sinful
and I think this have most religious
Christians and most religious Jews feel
and while that's awkward
yeah we're still friends in spite of it
which is why we're friends well in spite
of it then are you a bad thing well look
when I when I did your interview show
which by the way I mean yeah you Jack
the idea of an interview show from me
it's alright but nobody but what you
said that to me and and I truly mean
this like if you think what I'm doing is
sinful like I did I know it sounds glib
but I don't care all right and then I
use you don't have to every country like
right like that's the thing and it's
like look look there is of course
someone's gonna go well wait a minute if
you really think his marriage is sinful
or saying of course they'll there may be
a place that in the nature of our
friendship may be that we can't quite
get to that I would be able to get to
with someone that didn't think for sure
that is very possible and and and it
goes both ways right like I then look at
you and I go well why that's a kid you
don't want me teaching your kid about
the nature of family perhaps right I
mean like they're simply rights but
you're probably a pretty good dad like
you know what I mean like but why is it
that we're able to do this and most
people can't do this that's what I'm
curious and we can have our own lives I
mean that's that's real and I think part
of friendship by the way is that like we
go home at night we just have our own
lives yeah I'm not married to you right
that's like my wife and I have to agree
on these issues you and I don't have to
agree on these issues in order for us to
share a common space together and that's
really the important you think your wife
and you have to agree on these on all of
these issues or just
the sort of foundational and the
foundational ones but I do you think
that you know how you raise your kids
religiously and and with regard to
things like sexual morality does
actually have to be at the root of how
you teach your kids yeah so if you have
deep if you have deep divisions with
your spouse on these issues I think that
and you're looking to build a family
anyway yeah then I think that these are
issues were building on a bad foundation
is a bad move so ok ok so if you
wouldn't bake me a cake that's ok and
now because it's 50/50 I can't bake you
a cake which David's mom I'm not chef
and he would have done it kosher the
whole way you want it done for you you
got me this close putting that aside you
can't have a good kosher cake now if we
were having an anniversary party would
you come if I was inviting all the crew
that we all know and we were just an
anniversary party we're just having a
party and and I'll even throw in some
kosher food for you to make sure you
don't have to bring your own you know
I'd say I'd have to think about it I'd
have to think about it in the same way
so that's interesting to me yeah that's
that's a different thing well it not
really because again it's if you're a
religious person again take it from the
religious perspective that from the
religious perspective the question is
are you glorifying something that you
think is sinful yeah so this is a party
for something that you think was
originally sinful can you participate in
that so from a religious point of view
that's an actual serious moral question
yeah what I go out to dinner with you
the answer is yes right because that's
not actually like let's celebrate
something that I feel that you're doing
is sinful but I'd have to I'd have to
think about that one I'm at I mean I'm
perfectly honest right forward as
possible I want you but so it's to see
that's so interesting to me because it's
like if I threw a regular party just
we're at that party at my house and all
the guys that's right make you a cake
that had nothing to do with a gay
wedding right and I would go to a party
with you that has nothing to do with gay
marriage we do bake me a regular cake
could I just have a 32b again I mean my
baking sucks I'll buy you one I wanted
like Sapiro cake and then I'm gonna face
a crap I mean it's not gonna be good but
it's is that it'll be there I do think
Silicon Valley at this point has a bit
of a conformity problem it has you know
a bit of a way in which people are you
know too too much all thinking the same
way it's just like there was you know
the the Apple I saw this this meme on
the internet the other day where was
sort of the Silicon Valley 1997 : think
different that's Silicon Valley 2018 :
think the same it's like you only ask a
question why is it why is it so Soloff
to me I think these things are you know
there's somewhat over determined so I
would say part of it is is that it's
probably the most educated part of the
country in terms of how much time people
spent in college mm-hmm and I think one
of the downsides of too much education
is that you get the most brainwashed and
so it's it's it's the most educated can
also mean that it is it is the it is the
most brainwashed this is perhaps not so
true of the founders but certainly of of
many of the the rank-and-file people who
are on you know if you're sort of like a
really good engineer or you know really
good at some specific thing your
education typically does not involve you
thinking that much about about politics
and so it's not necessarily from deep
ideological conviction it's often more
as a fashion statement
than as a question of of power and so
and so one of the things it's always a
little bit hard to score is that even if
you took a survey in Silicon Valley it's
it's it comes out as you know quite far
to the left
you know weirdly uniform weird sort of
groupthink
it's super hard to know whether people
really believe this whether they're
whether they're just going along or so I
I think it's pretty liberal but but of
course not as liberal as it looks and
that's that's in a way worse because it
means people are too scared to
articulate things I think diversity is a
good thing I think especially you know
diversity of ideas mm-hmm is to be
valued but you don't have real diversity
when you just have a group of people who
look different and and think alike and
so it has to me it has to be more than
just you know than just having the
extras from the space cantina scene or
something like that right and and that's
and so that's always that's always so
it's always like an internal critique
the diversity myth is that it's it's not
about diversity at all it's about it's
about conformity but the point is we're
going to have to live with each other
as a nation and we're gonna have to love
each other and there are a lot of people
with this mimetic complex in their mind
this is why I went and I talked to Kanye
I thought what Kanye was going to do was
D Trump on
Magga with people who wanted their towns
in Ohio and western Pennsylvania to
start working again people who you know
we're drinking themselves silly feeling
that they were part of the American
Dream and got sidelined we are going to
have to find common closet it's just not
that hard you know it's just not that
hard to have a friend whose hue is
different than yours it's not that hard
to have a friend but you and I have
serious political differences at this
point it just doesn't cause me to want
to silence you
yeah and so my claim is is that even
though they're lying and even though
they know they're lying
you've got to experiment with love and
forgiveness to the best of your ability
and I can't tell you that I never lash
out I think I lashed out a little bit at
Rebecca Lewis because she was lying she
said it will never not be funny that the
entire intellectual dark web is only
located on YouTube oh really
so the 12 rules of life isn't a book
that exists and the waking up podcast
isn't something that has no video even
if it's it exists on YouTube people
listen to it off of YouTube is it it's
not true that we don't have any event of
course Rebecca Lewis is like she knows
she's lying data in society is lying
these people all know that they're lying
but they think that they're lying for
some beautiful reason to keep our
country together to make sure that we're
not in the hands of a tyrant to make
sure that every child has a shot at a
beautiful tomorrow and I'm sorry that
they're this confused but have some
compassion because they don't have the
compassion when we hear about empathy
okay the onus is on us
they don't have this great empathy they
like I so care about trans people that I
can't care about white people okay that
gives me a headache
you're either empathic and you care
about people in general
yeah or you it's selective empathy and
you really have a lot of hate in your
soul so I set a goddamn example that
that's my basic take which is you've got
to love the people who are lying
thinking that they're advancing the
world's cause and you have to love them
out of their cult
and if we're not willing to take that on
then I don't know what we're doing but I
can't always make this this high bar
that I'm setting for myself I will fail
I lash out at somebody but have a
forgiveness narrator there is in general
no redemptive redemption narrative on
the left that's why it's not even a
religion people say it's a cult it's
religion without a redemption narrative
there's nothing if what you're really
excited about is sticking it to the man
whoever the man is you're not
fundamentally a good person you're a
person who's working through your own
personal anger and so my claim is is
that love the people who are lying
against you and figure out what an
incredible power incredibly powerful
weapon that is because at the end of the
day after you knock them senseless to
the pavement you better offer them a
hand up and say look it wasn't personal
it's just you were you were threatening
our system and you know I felt like I
couldn't communicate to you while you
were still in the cult that's where I am
well there is a fear that if you
acknowledge that there are differences
between individuals or groups that
you're saying that one group is inferior
so there's been a the idea that we have
to be the same to be equal has been a
very prevalent and strong idea I don't
know who came where the idea comes from
but it's it's it's dangerous because if
you if you argue that no true equality
can be achieved unless we're all the
same then no true then we can't have
equality so however if you argue that no
we are all morally equal and that we
deserve equal opportunity and the equal
we deserve equal opportunities to live a
happy flourishing life however there are
differences between us yeah and you can
preserve that ethical principle so it's
very problematic for people who think
that there can be no equality between
men and women
unless we're proven to be the same
identical because the evidence doesn't
support the idea that we're the same but
look I've had so many years doing this
Dave and I can't explain how I still
love it I love the interplay yeah
you should love what you do yeah now you
know why you learn something every day
every day you learn so I can't be
closed-minded like I'm a liberal
politically certainly in social issues
but I'm not close-minded enough to think
that you can't have an opposing view
I like the argument I like the
discussion but in interviewing I never I
leave my ego at the door I try not to
use the word I it's irrelevant and I
tried to get in to walk any other you
know Edward Bennett Williams the great
lawyer told me once I said what is the
role of the criminal defense lawyer he
said to get one person on the jury to
walk in your clients shoes if you can
get one person to walk in your client's
Jews got a hung jury all he has to do is
say I would have done that I've been in
spaces at Columbia for example or
conversations where my being black it
was obvious to me that there was an
assumption of of moral worthiness or of
a kind of heightened moral knowledge and
I would have as a black person that a
white person wouldn't have and you know
I think I think I'm not the first to
make this analogy of course but the
religious analogy and the analogy to
original sin is pretty apt because it I
mean the way though this has a lot to do
with black history also because the way
oh the way I see it they're kind of two
ways to study history there's the
conventional way which is you know you
study World War one you study the causes
and consequences read different takes on
on the significance and once you've
studied all you need to
no you move on to the next topic but
then there's a religious way of studying
history which is I mean it's not enough
to know the facts we have to go
somewhere on Sunday and every single
week and learn talk about the same
stories over and over again so this is
you know it's it's the difference
between how an atheist learns about the
life of Jesus and how a Christian learns
about the life of Jean Jesus and re
learns at every week for the rest of
their life in my view how we're looking
at the history of race relations in this
country the history of racism we are
more and more putting it in the
religious category of history where you
know I can read a piece about the
history of lynching in the new york
times almost you know once every two or
three months right well I mean lynching
is a decade's old crime at this point
and obvious right obviously it was a
heinous stain on this country's legacy
you know but then the number of deaths
that that is is the highest amount
quoted in new york times with regard to
how many black people were lynched in
this country is around four thousand
right every single year twice that many
black people die of homicide and i you
just don't even hear about that in the
new york times there are 20,000
engineers engineers making between two
and four hundred thousand dollars
working right now just on google search
just on that one feature of google
twenty thousand this is the most
technologically advanced and powerful
organization in the history of the world
its technology and capabilities so far
outstrip those of the Pentagon for
example or the Chinese military or the
Russian no questions or any other group
this is the most powerful technological
entity in the world which has a choke
hold on all human information in English
so that is sort of all you need to know
I don't care if Jesus is in charge of
the country that's too much power for
any entity to have and it's a it's a
threat to the nation-state actually and
it's a threat to all of us so yeah I
think whatever it takes is what we need
to do like now you know I'm an alignment
guy but the thing is is that when I look
backwards in time you know what
what people like Harrison Pinker
attribute to the Enlightenment I see as
the Enlightenment being the latest
flowering of a process that was
indescribably older than that is exactly
right and in then in the and in the
historical sense certainly grounded in
the religious traditions but and then
from my perspective grounded in
something that's biological that's far
deeper than that like like our true
proclivity towards admiration for
competence and reciprocity
[Music]